foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
studying the lymphatic system using
light sheet microscopy
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by milteni biotech to learn more
visit multenibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Eben
lundgard PhD associate professor Lund
University Sweden
we will now have a brief introduction
from Dr Eliza nent
hello and welcome everybody to our
webinar today my name is Elizabeth I'm
the product manager for Neuroscience
working at midney biotech and I'm very
happy
um to introduce you the webinar about
studying the clymphatic system using
light sheet microscopy by Ebel lunkart
and before we go on and even starts I
will give a short introduction and also
tell you a little bit about miltoni
biotech
so just some fast facts the company was
founded in 89
expanded and so right now we have over 4
000 employees worldwide from over 50
nationalities
um a quarter of our employees are
working in r d so we are still
developing
um a lot and trying always to be
Innovative and on top of research
you can see here some examples about our
Technologies from Whitney biotech so I
will not go into detail but I hope you
can appreciate that we try to cover many
different Technologies and many areas to
give freely a lot of benefits to the to
researchers in the lab
so coming to the um
solutions that we have especially for
Neuroscience which I think are most
interesting for you today as you can see
here in this image we created this to
kind of show that we have several
approaches so on one hand we have kind
of
um a dissociating brain because we have
a workflow that you can use to
dissociate the brain tissue and isolate
cells but we also have on the other hand
the workflow for the Imaging of the
brain which I think are both quite
important approaches to study the brain
and um just very shortly so that you get
an overview our workflow for this
dissociation for the analysis
um starts with sample preparation where
we have dissociation kits and the gentle
mixed like an automated dissociator for
a sales separation we have different
microbeads that are labeled magnetic
beads to isolate cells for a psychiatra
we have media and supplements and for
the analysis we have a flow analyzer and
sorter
but then more important
um for today is our Imaging workflow
where we have a set of antibodies
clearing it and the nice
microscope that I will also explain you
further in the next slides
um which is really working hand in hand
and makes this approach to study the
brain in 3D more easy
so our other antibodies for especially
for 3D immunofluorescence
have a low cost they are all
fluorochrome conjugated which gives you
a faster results so it's easier than
working with the first primary and
secondary antibody and they're
recombinant and give you reproducible
data
and then for the next step the tissue
clearing
um maybe most of you or some of you have
heard of this basically what you do is
you render the tissue transparent by
this we add ethanol for the dehydration
and the solvent for the matching of the
refractory index which then as you can
see here turns the brain tissue within
several hours almost transparent making
it possible to then analyze really every
layer of the brain
we have a different tissue clearing
reagents like solution and the kit
um they are so organic solvent and
non-toxic which means they are quite
safe but still work fast and efficient
we have several protocols that are
directly optimized for example for the
brain and are quite easy to use
coming down to the ultra microscope
Blaze so this is also what will be later
mentioned in ebens talk this is a light
sheet microscope and you can see here
some examples about when it was used in
in several Publications for the analysis
of the brain for example but also for
other tissue
and um latching microscopy actually
covers this gap which you can see here
in the
microscopes that you maybe heard of
before conflict microscopy to
photomicroscopy that cover more the
smaller sizes in the cell let's say or
the MRE that covers directly the whole
brain and then kind of in the middle is
this Ultra microscope
um which is kind of showing
structures but also kind of includes the
whole brain anatomy so you can even
track connections of neurons or see
their location within the whole organ
um and some features of the place is
that basically you are able to image
large or even multiple samples
um
which means that you have directly a
high output and but still reduced
Hands-On time
uh what is also
very nice that it works fully automated
so that's quite easy it can be operated
by every lab member and you don't have
to sit so much yourself on the
microscope you can let it work for you
and we have a
set of different
optimized Optics which give you a higher
data quality but also High sensitivity
so as a summary and I don't want to take
too much time of you today just to
highlight that this Ultra microscope
Blaze is a fully automated light sheet
microscope which can image multiple
samples with a higher resolution it has
Cutting Edge Optics that provide a high
image quality and sensitivity and is
enabling to image large scale 3D organs
at a high resolution
and and with this
um I'm at the end of my part
um and I just wanted to show you here
this nice video of a brain that was
image with the um place
um but now actually I want to continue
um and in the end now introduce to you
our speaker of today which is even long
card
so um ibin is an associate professor at
the London University and is the
principal investigator of a research
group of around 12 people that are
studying the climatic system in the
context of neurological diseases the lab
was founded five years ago and has since
then published many papers and high
impact journals so the lymphatic system
is actually quite new and it's an
exciting topic that becomes more and
more relevant in Neuroscience so maybe
you've heard of this also before and
that's why you are tuning in on Eddie
were just interested to hear more about
the lymphatic system
but in any case I'm very much looking
forward now to her talk I think it's a
very exciting topic and I think with
this I'm at the end so even thanks for
agreeing to give this talk and the the
virtual stage is now yours
foreign
welcome to this lab root webinar on the
Confederate system and live stream
Imaging
my name is even mooncat and I'm an
associate professor at Lund University
all right so today I will be talking
about what the cliphatic system is
a little bit about why we think the
globetic system is important in relation
to neurodegeneration
then about
um our appropriation of slide sheet
microscopy and some data using YG
microscopy
that we used to study identifying system
in the face
and then I'm going to go through some
more considerations that you might want
to take into account when you decide on
whether or not to use I achievement
microscopy
but first I will actually start talking
about this through the spinal fluid
so it's produced and required plexus
here in the ventricles
and this is a ventricular system you see
here most people know in the CSF as a
way to measure biomarkers
but how do the biomarkers actually get
to the brain
so what you see here is the progression
of Alzheimer's disease
but you also see that the first
detectable events is the presence of
amyloid beta in the CSF
so then that makes the question how do
these biomarkers produce inside the
brain actually get to incisive
this is something about the lymphatic
system can explain
so it was discovered in 2012 in the lab
with making Miracast and it is the
system of perivascular influx of suicide
so the csap was circulating in the
suburbanon space and when these PL
surface idle is turned into penetrating
algories
the fluid is a self-flexibly follow
and you also see here that this arteries
are bounded by the astrocytes
and they're surrounding them and we know
now that the echo point four channels
expressed in the astrocytes are vital or
the distribution of suicide from the CSF
spaces to the brain or in comma
so in essence the lymphatic system
is is food transport system first we
have the influx of the clean CSF and
this in turn mediates appearance of
solids from the polynomial
so it's important clearance system
and interestingly is only active in the
Sleep state
and luckily for us also
um when anesthetized one with certain
anesthetics that have a high proportion
of
delta waves there's something normal
sleep
so there are some very interesting links
between sleep and nutrition and that the
lymphatic system might actually be able
to explain so it was a known from
previous studies that sweep the position
and Alzheimer's Minds cause exacerbation
of the plant load in this noise
also in humans it is later shown that
the more hours that you sleep the less
amyloid we have in our brain
so the lymphatic systems sparked a new
interest in sleep as a way to prevent
Alzheimer's disease
so we think that the lymphatic system is
also important in order to study in
relation to assames disease for example
and then some links between aquapore and
four channels which in the brain are
only exposed by ostracized and
Alzheimer's disease
here you see
Alzheimer's disease a minus architect
type PPP here's one
and
what you see here is that when the mice
will crossed and then we went at the
point form and the deletion minus and
look out nice
there was an exacerbation of the Android
pathology and also the mice showed words
cognitive performance when the lymphatic
system was inhibited
in act 1 4 and about mice
so we know now that according for net
hours and exacerbates the energy
pathology in mice
also
and in post-mortem studies aquapon 4
utilization to the vascular toe so the
correct
localization of aquapon form
was found to be disrupted in pastamic
disease patients
so this is why some of the reasons why
we think the lymphatic system is really
important to study in order to the ones
in order to generative diseases
so now to some of the mystery studies
that we did we have some cleared mice
and our ultimate scope please and
Achieve microscope
so how do we make scissors transparent
or we can also ask why are tissues not
transferred
so we've probably noticed something
that's
when a light when light travels through
different uh kind of
um
materials
it will change direction
so here you see for example I want a
light beam there's first struggling
through air then it changes Direction
when when it enters and exits a gel
so this is the same
thing that is happening in eye tissues
so this is because of the differences in
the refractive indices
so light is both
um absorbed and it is also refracted
so particularly when
one light moves through a an aqueous
solution
which would be inside or outside the
cells and then when they move through
they use cell membrane that has a high
lipid constant
so
the the most kind of basic
um premise for
for
Optical clearing is in homogenization of
refractive indices
so this will make the tissues appear
more transparent
and the basic steps that we use is
dehydration deliberation the optical
material so substitution are effective
and indices using another solution
and then we can use it for light Shield
Microsoft
interestingly
the first version of optical clearing
was actually performed more than 100
years ago
and by this bouncyhost
and
um he used Optical theory in this little
bit more primitive form so that we could
draw human organs to
um
to use an addresses
today there are a number of different
protocols available
we use the the Disco series and
specifically we use itisco Plus
and we have substituted uh one
chemical that I will mention later
so
so yeah this is the general
steps which consist in just 10 new
Solutions so it's very easy method
and we have substituted a type inside
ether for ethylene cinnamon as a thio
cinnamon plus the same effective index
but it is non-toxic actually it's used
as a food editor
then if you want to clear not organs or
for example whole mice
you can also do this with a few
additional steps
so here we have used the V discover
method and we've performed the
conversation and D classification
and then our regular steps
and
um here we're also injected with that in
this yourself and
um we can now see this in the whole that
body of the mouse
and we also see here how the green
Channel
and 48 channel can be used to obtain
structural information
so it has higher background than the
other channels
it can be a pain if the floor far of
interest
is in the green Spectrum but
if not it's very good too to get the
whole structure
okay so live stream across quickly
the principle is very simple
and illumination
comes
not in the same
and direction as the lens part comes
perpendicular to the Imaging units
and
often you will see illumination from
both sides
and then the light sheet is stable but
the sample moves
um up and down so that you can capture
the whole
the whole sample
so let me use the technology as for
example the optimize group plays will
use six sheets of light
and three from each side
and you see how compared to on the left
or right side elimination we've given a
little bit more detail by using
elimination on both sides
and some some Nightshade microscopes
also have this software so they actually
adjust
um the light sheet and the Imaging so
one image one field of view is made up
by uh by many different images so that
the light sheet is as focused as
possible on that field of view
so this is
one of the very new microscopes and they
like it the ultimate took place that
we're very happy with and I will go
through
um
uh some of the specifications so here
you see our beautifully cleared mice
and this is an air and when I'm resting
fluids they become even more transparent
so this is what we used in
foreign
sheet Imaging but I should say here when
we first set up the segment we were
using the previous version the ultra
microscope sure
um and so
using a live stream across with me to
image the lymphatic system for the first
time we felt that it was necessary
to run some tests so here we compared
positron anesthetics where we know the
digital static system is self-optimally
active and we compare this to academic
science and
um anesthetized mice where we know that
electronic system should be equally
active as in the Sleep state
so here we see
and the results from 3D with
instructions
so we found that we were able to
reproduce the differences between the
isotron and cyrusine
Originals when we used a multi
microscopene
and we also found that of course we
could
by sampling the entire brain which for
livestream Imaging into thousands images
of the mouse brain we were able to
perform additional segmentations
and we also saw that
the electronic system was more impaired
in the in the dorsal and the interior
parts
when using ice cream and sticks
so then
um
going forward we are interested in using
machine machine learning algorithms to
investigate
the lymphatic system in the entire Mouse
frame
but
um so far we have used
we have used in machine learning
algorithm to segment out the masculature
so not the the respiratory but the
vascular tree so we have seen that in in
the experimental autoimmune encephalom
myelitis model which is a model of MS
we had observed these mice were hypoxic
which could be partially all the valid
and by inhalation of 100 oxygen
so we wanted to
um
to analyze the refused vasculature
so we used an intravascular diet that
would only label the vascular mature of
the profuse blood vessels and we saw
that
um in terms of the perfused vasculature
we're able to
um
to here for the spinal cord determine
the total the fused lungs and the
perfused the radius of the capacitor
any verification points
by combining light Shield Imaging and
machine learning algorithms in
collaboration with the Alia circular in
Munich
then we also used nausea microscopene to
study the confounded system in higher
memos
so besides this obvious difference in
size
then the big brain here is also a giant
cephalic
so it has a gyri and sulfide in between
whereas the mouse brain is nucensophilic
smooth
also the pig brain has larger arterioles
whereas the mouse brain mainly consists
of papillars
and
um
other
[Music]
advantages for using larger mammals such
as pigs
is that they have a more similar
physiology to humans
so what we saw here in the thick brain
was that in the lymphatic system and
here we are tracking the operations is
the shaft and we're looking at how it
distributes to the peak brain here we
have a communal slice and we saw that in
the series of time was concentrated in
this fissures on the Society of the big
brain
and what was very important was that the
tracer was seen in purple
was also localized in the perimascular
space between endothelial cells and
astrocytes on the outside
so this tells us that the micro
architecture of the lymphatic system is
the same so in larger
mammals when we've seen some
self-distributed with brain
it also does that in a periovascular
manner
then it is some light sheet microscopene
now we have the circus like the brain
then we're looking at the inside of the
brain and this is just the the very
lowest magnification uh that we can
actually use so what you see here is
this very robust and highly regular
pattern of CSF influx here in white
which is moving into the brain into the
brain is up
in this direction
so that's the cortex and then in another
campus we see here some larger vessels
where we see a surf chaser with able to
move much further than along the smaller
caliber
platypuses
and when doing a comparison here we saw
that the the entry points for system
influx was about four times higher in
pigs than in the mouse cortex
and also saw that
there's himself turned it further along
with larger calendar
arterials so we believe that the
lymphatic system is is not only
conserved but it's also you know perhaps
even evolutionarily enhanced in larger
mammals
so to summarize here for the parts and
the conflict system
petrified system is a clearance system
that uses perivascular pathways
so it's kind of piggybacking on the
vasculature but it is moving only in the
periascular pathways
light sheet Imaging is feasible and for
lymphatic studies
we saw that in the cell C and the fishes
and large jarified Brain act as highways
or recessive movement
so
um we found that the lymphatic system is
emotionally conserved if not enhanced
by the verification of large brains
and
as I mentioned before
the lymphatic system May provide links
as to
why sleep and get a Sleep Quality
um is reducing the risk for
neurodegenerative diseases such as
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's disease
so we're interested in starting the
geometric system and would hope to to
find out how it works with the goal to
be able to enhance or just sustain this
function in aging
and now to some considerations
if you if you want to get into light
shoot
um
acroscopy
um so we'll go through some
specifications here and some
considerations
first the size of the sample
so I would say if you're only planning
to use a few hundred
microns and say up to maybe 100 microns
of thickness then you may even use a
confocal microscope but if you have
whole
organs
of of my sensing one then you can
benefit from using potassium
microscaping
so here so you want to in terms of
the sample size you want to be able to
to of course physically fit it into your
chamber and you also want to check the
the travel range of the microscope
in addition to this we also have to
consider the working distance
because this means here for our 1X lens
the working distance is 1.7 centimeters
which is some of the highest working
distance for the microscopes out there
at the moment actually and that would
mean that if your sample is 1.7
centimeters thick then it means to image
the bottom the lens is actually on the
top of the sample
so see how this varies with different
magnifications of lenses
then you have a solution can you get the
resolution that you want
so for this you want to of course look
at the the lens magnification the total
magnification including a zoom
and your numerical aperture let's give
you gives you this and this maximum
resolution
the image quality
the image quality here you want to look
at how many light shoes can you get so
six this would be three from each side
then
your thickness this is your a light
sheet thickness we usually use five
microns
and then is your clearing protocol
compatible here you want to look at the
compatibility with refractive indices
and often you will find that you can use
both the water-based
um protocol or
in dbe or Ethan CineMate based protocol
then how much throughput can you get
this of course depends on how much you
can fit into the microscope but also in
terms of the software if you can
um if you can set up the microscope for
acquiring uh several samples in one
session
so this is more automated
foreign
biotech
[Music]
here we had to split the mouse head in
two to to fill it in the entire size
now with the new microscope we can image
the whole head now we've inject the
dinosaur moving through the head
to the periphery here from going to the
grocery and we're gonna loop back
so we see how the brain in this entirety
and we also see some cervical lymph
nodes
so this new microscope has been a big
um Improvement in terms of technology
for us
okay so some more considerations
um here so
so you can use organ only for example
with the eye disco protocol or you can
use the whole body
here you have to continuously
um
diffuse
um
the different chemicals Solutions
into the body
then
um
then what kind of fluorophore will you
be using do you have an endogenous or
injector fluorophore so we are so lucky
to use our synthetic deterior for us you
may have for example
um a report a mouse with a fluorescence
protein
and if not you are of course reliant on
antibody staining
but having said that you might want to
be aware that if you use a fluorescent
reporters and this includes dfp
reporters you might need an
amplification of the signal by antibody
labeling
because some of these fluorescence and
proteins
are not as bright after the whole
clearing protocol
foreign so if you want to use an
antibody labeling there is a number of
protocols out there
and it is good to check
um in published papers if someone has
used antibodies against the epitope that
you are interested in
as antibody labeling requires
optimization for each antibody
and some antibodies may not actually
work
so here for example you can do a
methanol and a test testing
um whether the antibody still works
and if not you can try another antibody
this is if you use a
methanol in your and clearing protocol
of course
as we do
so and some summary here I'm doing my
cheek microscopy parts
so you want to consider your sample size
if you have a sample size less than 100
microns you may be able to use confocal
if you use a lighter sample sizes you do
have to check the the sample size and
the specifications of your
lightsheed microscope
several microscopes they can only image
one or cubic centimeter
then in terms of the clearing protocol
if you use a
if your sample is one organ
you can get away with a simpler protocol
but you can even clear
whole bodies of mice using other
clearance protocols
then you can also consider substituting
some of the toxic chemicals
for example the type in cell ether which
is which is the last step of the Addis
called Plus
protocols
and because this means that this will be
the liquid that you use in the
microscope also
so only a few
um institutions will have their light
sheet microscope placed with ample Point
suction
so here you can replace for example a
dbe to
um to ethyl cinnamate so that you're not
exposed to toxic chemicals while Imaging
yeah consider your floral Forest if you
can use
um Fire Red
fluorophores it is recommended as the
penetrate the tissues better
remember that
um
the most out of fluorescence you will
get on the green channel so in the gfp
Spectrum
and
[Music]
um
antibodies will not always work with the
clearing protocols so so each antibody
has to be
tested so it can also be an idea to test
several antibodies in parallel
so with that I would like to thank my
amazing team
and
Tecla and
Mario's Na and Nick have been working a
lot with the light Shield Imaging in the
lab
I would like to thank uh collaborator
who
SE help with the machine learning
algorithms
for segmenting out the
vascular compartment and it took in
Munich
I would like to thank my funding and I
would like to thank elabroads for
hosting this
webinar
and with that I would be happy to take
questions
thank you Eben for your informative
presentation if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box and
click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
which tissues are the hardest to clear
yep so um I can I can start by saying
that I'm fortunate to work with the with
brain tissue and bring tissue clearness
amazingly
um but for example it's known that
hemoglobin gives a lot of
autofluorescence so this is why you
start for the confusion step but also
myosinophen so that would be in muscle
tissue including the heart
um so I would say the muscle tissue is
probably the tissue that that is the
hardest to clear
and however there is
um at least one paper that that
describes and the test different kind of
tiering protocols
and for for clearing of the heart
so I would say that any any tissue can
be cleared
great thank you our next question asks
what can be done if the gfp reporter is
not working
uh yes
this is actually something that we are
dealing with at the moment
and so we have a recorded Mouse
expressing egsp and
and unfortunately the gfp signal is not
visible after the clearing so what we're
trying now is that we are using
nanobuddy and labeling so this means
it's a truncated version so it's a
smaller molecular weight version of an
antibody
which is directly conjugated to
fluorophore so with basically amplifying
the egfp signal in that way and we're
also testing other
clearance protocols than the Disco
family of protocols that we normally use
in order to to retain the etfp signal in
our report mice
great our next question asks how many
channels can be imaged with light sheet
microscopy
yes so on our light sheets microscope we
have a seven
emission excitation filters uh
excitation emission filters
uh
installed but at the moment we would
like to stick to two
fluorophores and but so we know for
example
that the fire red fluorophore is very
good we also know that in the lowest
nanometer range so for the blue lights
it carries most energy but therefore
it's absorbed more and that's penicated
yes so right now we're actually only
doing two four fours green and far red
and but I've seen other labs that
managed to get a resolution of of more
for foreign
foreign
thank you our next question asks how
relevant is the order of clearing steps
for the results for example
decolorization and declarification prior
or after dehydration or permeabilization
okay that is a good question and we
haven't tried to to switch the order so
of course that could be
strides but I believe it makes perhaps
more sense to do the the colorization
step
first because I think this is more water
soluble and then if you are using the
Disco protocols as we are your later
dehydrating the tissue and so after that
you don't want to
re-introduce water molecules because
then you have
[Music]
um
yeah then you have solvents but not
actually water
great our next question is
was the cubic LR method successful in
your hands
we we haven't tried it yet but due to
this um issue with the with the loss of
fluorescence in our EGP reporter miles
um we may we may actually try it
but we haven't we haven't tried it yet
thank you our next question is what is
the main advantage of light screen
microscopy
yeah the main advantage yeah that's a
nice question so so I would say this is
this is for the for the Miso scale or or
perhaps even microscopic in imaging
so if you if you have a tiny sample like
I said less than 100 microns then the
confocal microscopy
um I would probably find would be
superior so so it's really really useful
when when you have larger samples and
such as a mouse organs or even
um if you want to image the whole mouse
body because there you get
you get a much much improved resolution
to for example a act or MRI imaging
so so this is this is really the the
advantage is the improved resolution for
larger samples
great and it looks like we have one more
question here today and that is are you
open to collaborations
yes yes we are often uh open to
collaborations and
um we we really love this technique and
we found it pretty easy to to get
started so we'll be happy to help others
to
and to get started or do test Imaging of
their samples if they don't have a light
shade microscope in their Institution
and so
so yeah I I find this technique very
very fascinating and uh
and um
yeah has really helped us to to enter
more of our research questions
so we would be happy to help other
groups get started with this
foreign
thank you even it looks like we have one
more question that actually came in here
and it asks how do you use titrate
antibodies for 3D microscope microscopy
uh yes good question so a little bit
um
primitive but but if I have suspended uh
way
um what we do is that we would try
um we would try three concentrations of
antibody one would be
um the same antibody as we would use for
a normal say slice staining and then we
would go a little bit under and then we
would go and perhaps several times
higher than that
so this would be
um yeah a test that we would run in
parallels or simultaneously because uh
yeah the antibody penetration takes
um for the brain say a week and for a
larger samples we would use three weeks
so
we'll always run these different
concentrations
and in parallel
great thank you we have another question
that came in here and it says the
disadvantage of light screen microscopy
is it difficult to perfectly align both
light sheets in three-dimensional space
so what you want what do you have to say
about that
mm-hmm
yeah I believe that is question
um could be maybe relevant based on the
exact type of light shade
um microscope that you use
and so we
um I I believe we're quite fortunate
with the model that that we have now and
I don't get the paid to advertise for
this microscope but I'm gonna really
find it fantastic
um so so and what what is this new uh
and particular model of the light shade
microscope does is that for one field of
view
uh it will actually adjust
um the light sheet so so that it would
take uh multiple images I think maybe
standard of 32 images
uh just to put into one image for one
field of view so we haven't had any
issues with the alignment uh I believe
it's done maybe in the service check
once a year
um and it works beautifully the rest of
the time and so at least for the model
that we use it's it's not an issue and
and the software
editions like I said that it is
capturing many images to get one field
of view
and this is there's a really good
Improvement for for the for the image
quality to get it really crisp
everything in focus and it illuminated
uh so so for us alignment of the light
Shield has not been an issue
great thank you so much even it looks
like that brings us to the end of our q
a session for today do you have any
final comments for our audience
it's like uh well I just like to say
thank you for attending this webinar and
thank you for the questions they're all
great questions and and I hope that this
has to spurred you on to to perhaps use
a light sheet for for your own research
great thank you again even for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor multani biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye